acids and bases are everywhere they're
used to make foods soaps and detergents
fertilizers explosives dyes plastics
pesticides even paper our stomachs are
very acidic our blood is slightly basic
our proteins are made up of amino acids
and the letters in our genetic code
those a's t's c's and g's are all bases
you are probably taught how acids and
bases behave on the molecular level you
are probably never taught that a long
time ago like ancient greek ago before
anyone knew about atoms or molecules
acids and bases were defined by how they
behaved acids tasted sour and corroded
metal bases felt slippery and could
somehow counteract acids when molecules
dissolved in water interact they're
exchanging two main currencies with
their surroundings protons also known as
hydrogen ions and electrons depending on
how a molecule is composed or shaped it
may be willing to donate or accept
either protons or electrons with some
other community member and some
molecules are far more aggressive than
others when it comes to donating or
accepting either currency remember that
protons are positively charged and
electrons are negatively charged so if a
molecule is willing to give up a proton
that's not too different from it being
willing to accept an electron either way
it's becoming more negatively charged
other molecules are willing to accept a
proton or give up an electron these are
becoming more positively charged some
substances are so aggressive about
donating their protons that when they
get a chance all of the molecules in a
sample will dump a proton sometimes more
than one - the surrounding water
molecules we call these strong acids
meanwhile some compounds are so ready to
accept a proton that they won't wait
around
they'll just rip one off water which
usually has two protons but is generous
enough to hang out with just one we call
these strong bases other acids and bases
are not so strong they may donate just a
few of their protons to water or accept
just a few protons from water but most
of their molecules stay exactly the same
if left alone in water they'll reach
some equilibrium point where maybe only
one out of a hundred or one out of
10,000 of their molecules has exchanged
currency with water as you might guess
we label these acids and bases weak but
in the common sense of the word they're
not weak the vinegar in your salad
dressing that you can smell from across
the room that is a weak acid the ammonia
you spray on glass for a streak-free
shine that is a weak base so it doesn't
take much to be an active player in the
chemical economy most acid-base
chemistry takes place in water which can
act as either an acid or a base
accepting deposits and enabling
withdrawals like a 24 hour molecular ATM
and when a proton deposit customer
that's an acid and a proton withdrawal
customer the base shop at the same time
their net effect on waters account may
cancel out and we call this
neutralization now certain molecules can
behave as acids or bases without water
but that's another story let's end by
saluting water as the resilient and fair
banker for acids and bases it's always
open for business doesn't charge
interest and will never foreclose on
your molecules which is more than I can
say from wat Wat
Oh